les dangers et les excès de certains
sites internet le tribunal de paris se
penche aujourd'hui sur le cas de sites
néonazis et la possibilité d interdire
sujet très controversé car jusqu'à
présent la liberté totale sur le net
loïc de la mornais didier da vous avez
la voix nous avons les moyens
faites vous entendre fort de cette
invitation des centaines de sites nazis
racistes on trouvait accueil sur le
portail front 14 associations des femmes
pour l'unité aérienne musique du
troisième reich ou encore boîte mail du
ku klux klan c'est la première fois
qu'une telle concentration est recensée
sur la toile et sur un même site
à paris les associations antiracistes
ont vite réagi en dépêchant pas moins de
quinze avocat pour porter plainte
on trouve sur ce site par exemple des
affiches de l'exposition 1942 comment
reconnaître le juif on trouve des choses
extrêmement choquante qui publié dans un
journal serait immédiatement condamné
l'internet n'est pas au dessus des lois
c'est ce que nous entendons voir appris
aujourd'hui
originalité de cette plainte au
contraire du récent procès contre le
site yahoo
les associations mettent en cause cette
fois ci les fournisseurs d'accès
autrement dit des entreprises comme aol
ou club internet accusé de ne pas assez
filtrer le contenu qui circulent dans
leurs tuyaux
c'est le problème de l'impalpable
internet pour les avocats de la défense
les fournisseurs d'accès non pas la
technologique pour tout contrôler et
techniques filtrage sont totalement
insuffisantes surtout lorsqu'elles sont
limitées à quelques fournisseurs d'accès
puisque l'on connaît toutes les
solutions de contournement qui existent
notamment par la voix d'autres
fournisseurs d'accès que ce soit en
france ou à l'étranger d'ailleurs
avant de prendre sa décision le tribunal
entendra des experts sur les techniques
de filtrage mais la justice prendra
aussi l'avis de sociologues et de
philosophes comme alain finkielkraut
derrière ce jugement rendu dans un mois
c'est aussi une réflexion sur la sacro
sainte liberté d'expression sur internet